ahora mismo nos encontramos en la ciudad
de Alejandro y tonadas más afectadas por
el terremoto que se acudió hace justo
una semana el sureste de Turquía del
Norte oeste de Siria en esta ciudad en
alejandreta los dos hospitales que antes
la servían han quedado parcial o
totalmente dañados uno es completamente
inutilizable y el segundo tiene solo la
mente la parte de emergencias que puede
ser utilizada por sus ciudadanos por lo
tanto la agencia de cooperación española
ha montado en este lugar en un sitio de
exposiciones un hospital de campaña con
capacidad para 20 camas con servicios de
cirugía y de tratamiento también
psicológico y de atención primaria ahora
mismo sobre todo lo que nos explican a
los servicios aquí desplazados desde
España que abrieron esta misma mañana Es
que la mayoría de los pacientes que
llega son gente que tiene necesidades
muy básicas Como por ejemplo fiebre
anginas problemas ginecológicos y de
otro tipo estas personas serían
normalmente en una situación normal en
un hospital Turco Pero a este esos
hospitales están completamente
colapsados y por lo tanto ahora mismo
las tareas sobre todo de este hospital
de campaña son las de la atención
primaria los ciudadanos perdido todo
muchos de los que pasan por aquí
explican que ya no tienen casa uno
estábamos hablando hace con ellos hace
poco que salió el mismo de las runas de
su casa y tenía daños en las dos piernas
ha sido tratado en este hospital también
hay servicio para para que puedan llegar
personas con mayor urgencia también nos
expliquen que sobre todo ahora mismo lo
que esperan que les llegue no es tanto
personas de debajo de las runas como si
de accidentes de tráfico que siguen
ocurriendo al final después de una
catástrofe como esta muchas personas
millones de personas que aún siguen en
esta región siguen necesitando de ayuda
sanita